three days before my father died I
looked at his in his eyes and I had the
most profound conversation that I'd have
to that moment of my life and there was
no word spoken
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Alan Saki on we are still on
site at the transformative technology
conference this is our second
partnership with them we are now
speaking with Charlie Hartwell hi
Charlie hey Alan how are you thanks for
coming on the program it's good to be
here I was so excited for this
conversation Charlie let's as we're
gonna get into bridge builders I'm
excited we're gonna ask you some
questions to start first question yes
are we really all one it's so funny I
was talking to my wife about this two
days ago and I described my wife as the
wisdom of our family and and we were
talking about that it's like the answer
may be yes we are and yet we are
separate as well that's her wisdom
elaborate please so we're all connected
but we're we have our individuality and
so if we can understand that were
connected to everything but that we're
individual and we have our own unique
essence or whatever you want to call it
so we're part of that but we're we're
unique that makes sense
yeah so in this in in a sense they're as
nerve endings unique nerve endings of
creation experiencing itself
interconnected nerve endings that are
unique of creation experiencing itself
but I can still be you and I can be
Brady and you guys can be me and that's
the interconnectedness as well okay well
I don't know if you can be me you were
you were connected to me I'm my own
individuality
I'm my own unique essence I'm connected
to you we can be I've been connected in
you very unique ways
and I think one of my might and one of
my teachers a long time ago it's like
okay so if you're a drop in the ocean
you're the ocean mm-hmm but you're also
the drop in the ocean but then you go
into the ocean and then where's the drop
and your drop can't be my drop in my
drop can't be your drive I'm I'm not
saying we're part of each other we're
part of the oneness okay we're connected
yes but I think I'm a unique essence and
we can interact our essences can
interact
okay okay unique essences in the oneness
okay okay okay
how about so we started there where we
going now we are there we are always
here I love it how about your own
experiences of the interconnectedness
your own experiences of maybe ego loss
or unconditional love or the present
deep present moments
so I think the for me I grew up in a
family where I was not unconditionally
loved so in my own process of awakening
it was learning how to be unconditional
love to myself and then you know just
experiencing unconditional love and
understanding that that doesn't need to
come from other people that we can find
that within ourselves and that we can in
and then we can find it the
unconditional love from you know comes
from other places as well I don't know
if that answers your question
and it's only part of your question
music it's what are the other the other
things
yeah feelings of interconnectedness ego
loss deep present moment nurse I was
just talking to a guy who you know from
the perspective of connectedness who you
know felt a heart attack of somebody
else 1,500 miles away called said is he
having a heart attack the answer was yes
four years later same thing happened
felt that happened called and said is
some of the so and so having a heart
attack and yes person said yes and and
then it has there been one in between
those times and the answer was no so
that's a pretty you know from thousands
of miles away
that's pretty connected it seems to me
it's at least it's an example yeah yeah
there's still much to understand about
the unity of creation but yet the
uniqueness of our essences
this is a very abstract point it is all
one yet the uniqueness of your essence
is expressing itself okay is that
something to understand or is that
something to experience experience
he said understand I was like I don't
know if you can that we can't understand
I'm not sure is it is it it is it is it
for understanding or is it for
experiencing like comprehending that can
it be both I don't know I think it can
be both could we understand all of
creation I don't think that's impossible
but is it impossible to create something
more beautiful than creation that may be
possible okay we just got there with our
lust with John conversation with John
yeah got it
yeah that there may not be anything more
beautiful creation yeah the only thing
that's impossible is to make something
more beautiful than creation how do you
feel about that statement I don't really
care deviations beautiful so why why
would I need to create something more
beautiful just experience the beauty of
this one do you think anything is
impossible besides making something more
beautiful than creation Wow is anything
impossible
I don't know
thank you for saying I don't I'm like
sitting here saying I need to have an
answer and I don't yeah yeah so I might
as well shut up yeah what are some of
the best strategies techniques keys
practices for us to have deeper feelings
towards that unity that
interconnectedness unconditional love
presence it's funny
so I speak at a lot of conferences and a
lot of Technology conferences and
because I'm an investor and look at lots
of different methods or paths or
whatever to achieve what you're talking
about and just say my favorite my
favorite way is getting enters through
the technology that's already been
created which is called mother nature so
just being out of nature that's it for
me individually that's just a great way
that's the best way to connect the quote
apparently is attributed to da Vinci but
that nature is the best teacher oh yeah
yeah I don't know if it's I don't know
if nate for me if nature is the best
teacher nature's the best experience to
connect with the teacher but ultimately
the ultimate lesson of the student is
the process of learning from the teacher
of creation about okay creation and in
nature being immersed in it is like the
ultimate classroom and teacher yeah yeah
yeah but that seems like that seems for
me that's almost too complex it's just
like get out and get on nature and just
see what Anjali just be and bliss
experience just watch watch yeah just
feel be connected yeah being Wonder for
that which you you know you look up at a
star and say it's not there anymore yeah
but there it is
or some nut yeah yeah Zima or some art
yeah but like when when you look at a
tree for more than three seconds if you
look for three minutes you see newer and
newer things emerge and you learn more
and more about the reality correct and
then you can learn to talk to it how do
you do that I'm not saying I did
how have you heard about a song once
called I mean yeah I think he
communicate with trees yeah I don't I
don't know how I would describe the
community they communicate yeah and so
what doesn't we don't
what does not communicate what do you
think what does not communicate I don't
does everything communicate everything
has energy everything transmits
something right
I don't know yeah I think I think in
some way shape or form but I think for
me more you know sort of living things
as opposed to inanimate objects would
communicate you know animals communicate
trees communicate flowers can
communicate mm-hmm how do we speak the
language of trees there's books about
that I don't I don't know if we yeah I
think you have to be sort of on a
different wavelength and not try to
speak to them like you speak to human
yeah yeah and I don't know how different
that would be then how do you learn to
you know communicate with animals I know
animal communicators know we use animal
communicators I've been on whale
watching trips with animal communicator
you know it's like they communicate I'm
not saying that that's my gift but I
know there are people that are and I
have enough personal evidence to know
it's a bit to believe that that's all
possible and and to have experienced
that it's true what do you think's the
purpose of creation the expression of
love maybe
what else besides that maybe a way to
grow
a way to love a way to grow mm-hmm all
of these experiences of all these
essences unique essence is experiencing
themselves unique essences experiencing
themselves experiencing creation
experiencing themselves gross love is
the illusion of separation the most
upstream issue that our society faces
say it again is the most upstream issue
that our society faces that's causing
them all most if not all of the issues
that we face is the illusion of
separation now that I mean so if you're
disconnected from love because you've
put some human barrier or perceived
human barrier to say you're separated
from that that's I would think that's a
root of a lot of suffering on the planet
you think available religions most
mostly patriarchy and all patriarchal
that I know about in the modern world
a group of people gets together men are
in charge men say you're separated and
that the only way you can be connected
is through something else they gain
power that's that they create an
illusion that creates a power dynamic
that keeps you or that might keep you
if you believe it in a place of thinking
that you are separated
why would creation want to make love and
gross I don't know what is it about
those two words for you love and growth
yeah I don't know what it is I guess
just experience and why those two
experiences what about the way they make
you feel why do you pick those two just
what came I don't know
now forever I will always remember love
and growth forever yeah yeah is that
your essence love and growth at some
core
I'd say love is my is my essence but in
this human form in my energy system I
would be about growth authentic
leadership innovation and transformation
so that's kind of in this body what I
bring onto this planet is the energy of
that
what does authentic leadership mean this
is bridge builders no this is everything
this is everything since I was a kid
yeah
just whatever sort of I've it seems to
me that when I get involved with
something something's gonna change and I
don't know if I'm answering your
question but that's just like if I look
back at my life and I think of the
things that I've chosen to get involved
with something is going to change
something is going to grow there's a
global movement associated with it and
and something's gonna transform and then
your question about authentic leadership
for me it's kind of like knowing your
purpose and expressing it fully and
being that
and removing the barriers to whatever
prevents you from doing that so the more
clear we become about what we are
blueprinted for as our essence the more
of an authentic leader we are I think
that's that's what I would believe and
so then you have a radar that you've
worked on that helps you identify that
radar might be a description that might
be one description there's I would say
you know radar combined with you know so
intent is an attention a radar if
intentions a radar then the answer to
your question is yes you know my life I
have sort of done certain things said
wow this looks cool I'm gonna get into
that and if that's a radar that sort of
said I want to do that then either
circumstance or intuition or something
happens and there I am and so I get this
is something I'd like to sink my teeth
into and then [ __ ] starts happening
what is the relationship between for you
your intuition presence and your future
my intuition my presence and my future
and you can maybe throw and then we
throw the word planning into that
intuition the intention because to me
that let him to me that's a lot of the
radar is in my experience and in really
i again you know credit my wife who's
really taught me a lot about this my you
know the intent it's like making
attention be present to what shows up
and then it may not look and then not
have not have a not not try to get in
your head and try to figure out what
that looks like and then watch the
beauty unfold it doesn't really work
that way i don't know for me it does so
you make an intention of a something and
manifests yeah
does this work for people that want to
be uplifted out of poverty and that want
and not experience disease and does it
work that way I don't know for them I
can always speak for me
and what my intentions are or have been
so like if I'm malnourished and I make
intention for nourishment
does nourishment come at for a lot of
people who doesn't so then how does that
work then why would it work in certain
cases and not in others this intention
yeah like I think we're talking about
something different and I don't if I say
I mean just go to nutrition you know I'd
like if I say I want a meal to show up
right now that's not gonna that's not
gonna happen to me either
like there's not going to be food is not
gonna fly through the window and so I
think there's a difference there's a
difference there
but I'm done I'm not sure that I'm that
I can describe it right now I don't and
then you know and I don't have an intent
like you said before like the future is
part of that so I don't know what the
you know a lot of the intentions that I
might set for my life
I make the intention I don't know when
that's going to show up in the future
necessarily I don't say I have an
intention for today and this is what
happens today I set an intention and
things show up in the future
regarding a part of your blueprint being
manifested the intention is there for it
but there is no time that it must occur
it's just the intention for it so having
an intent intention for abundance is
just an excellent intention an intention
of love there's just an excellent
intention just radiating love and
abundance and growth
that can be an attention so then this
coming to the ADA of those parts of our
essence that are the so called different
essences within the oneness that are
that are malnourished or that I may have
a pathology developing and they're set
in tension their essence the set
intention towards nourishment or
eradication of the disease sometimes
works and sometimes doesn't
so then wouldn't my intention for
abundance and intention for love and
intention for growth sometimes work and
sometimes not well I can't I can't speak
to the you know I can't speak to other
people's experience if you set an
intention for for love and abundance do
you know what that you know what that
necessarily looks like I don't think a
lot of people necessarily know what that
looks like I and you know to to go back
to the to the MAL nourishment certainly
I don't you know don't want people to be
malnourished but some of the happiest
people on the planet actually are and
something was a way that we or are not
in abundance the way we might look at
abundance in America for instance or in
the Western world so we might define
abundance as oh my god the house the
beach the all of that and actually the
way we define what is abundance what is
abundance correct so so you experience
or I hear stories or in my own
experience of licking in the slums in
Nairobi for instance some of the half
you know there's some incredibly happy
people in terrible situations some of
the most kind people had the least
amount of physical goods as we define it
and then I hear stories of people who go
get transformed because they're living
in our society in the capitalist
thinking abundance is about money wealth
etc and they find out that's actually
not what abundance is what then is an
intention for abundance how do you set
yours I'd might just set an intention
for abundance and then you indicated
their different abundances as though
someone that may have very little is
setting a completely different intention
for abundance than someone with so many
material but yeah okay but like you know
to me abundance is watching a sunrise
and the beauty of that to me that's very
abundant in the way that you might view
that you might view that there to people
watching that same sunrise and ones an
abundance and having an awe experience
and the other person is just watching a
sunrise so part of abundance would be oh
my god that is so beautiful and I'm
noticing more beauty around or whatever
it's a I think it's part of it's an
attitude so we may set abundance
intentions for abundance at something
like a sunrise or sunset we may set it
for
be ourselves to not be impacted by a
disease maybe a family member to get
through a disease and creation may
depending on that intention come in and
act there may be some sort of an acting
on that intention that happens a
manifestation of that disease being gone
from your family member so how do you
know that having the disease in the
first place
isn't part of the path to abundance and
I can speak to this directly you know in
my own experience of waking up and the
intention you know around that I there
was a lot of suffering there's a lot of
death and had I not gone through that
expand the universe was actually knowing
that I'm stubborn enough where it like
piled it on and so I actually had to go
through that in order to enjoy the
abundance or the richness of my life now
because for me personally I was not at a
place to probably receive what I'm able
to receive now and I didn't know myself
the way I knew now and I was living
under stories and conditioning that I'd
grown up with that caused a lot of
suffering so how do you know so it's a
great so I can say this the greatest
gift of my life was the death of my
father
and then how did you come to reckon with
okay he died you guys are laughing have
you been doing this all day
Wow
[Applause]
please continue continue the what the
greatest gifts if my life was the death
of my father please continue so in my
experience my dad my dad's death
combined
I'll just say this I struggled for a
long time my dad had cancer and in the
process of him having cancer and my my
business not working out the way that I
wanted it to and kind of being in being
in a marriage that had been dead so
they're like business dying father dying
marriage already dead four years without
really realizing it there got to be like
a moment where I had this dream that I
was climbing the World Trade Center and
I knew what I was gonna do when I got to
the top of it and I woke up and it's the
first time that I said I need help and
in my family system you didn't go get
help so but I went and got help and part
of that was in a sort of preparation for
my father's dying
when my father three days before my
father died I looked at his in his eyes
and I had the most profound conversation
that I'd had to that moment of my life
and there was no word spoken there was
no time there was no it was just like
everything that was going to change in
my life
was like it was just there like it was
just spoken it was we'd never had a
conversation with words there were as
powerful as the moments they looked into
my eyes it was cosmic it was whatever it
was but it was a soul talking to a soul
as opposed to a human talking to a human
and within that it was it was the
permission that he had not had in his
life to wake up and then knowing that
he'd be there for me
and he was and in his death he was more
therefore they need ever been in his
life
that and I explained that but it was
real
the greatest gift was this moment so
close to the death when you felt the
deepest connection yeah
how do we figure it out there is no way
Wow why did he show up so real
then I don't look first of all like like
to try to explain it to me to actually
takes away the power of it so I'll say
I'll say that yeah but mice but but if I
go into like he was at a place where he
could where he could access that you
know he was where he could have that
conversation he would have them have had
no framework or permission in his life
as he had known that to have a
conversation that was that
transformational and in his point of
getting ready to be you know to be to
move on to whatever you want to you know
describe it from his body he was he was
in a position to go that that deeply and
I was in a position to receive it heard
or you know I don't want to just say it
was one way from him to me it was both
it was a both and and you were uniquely
positioned to receive it at that time
yeah
[Applause]
when you say trying to understand the
why takes away the power from it may it
also help those that are listening more
better experience profound things like
it if I could just explain it could it
could us understanding Xperia T into the
feelings the beingness of that
interaction of you and your father being
the gift
Kedar dive into the depths of that be
deeply Awakening and inspirational for
people listening know if people are open
and holds an intention this conversation
may or may not be opening or not might
be something else that happens it's
completely mean who knows all I can say
is for me when you get into in my own
experience there is no explaining that
conversation there that it makes any
sense it is it is so profound that words
don't do it justice and
so when I try if I tried to explain it
it's a very head driven thing this was
had nothing to do with the head and this
had to do with a soul connection and I'm
not sure that can be explained or
believed you know for some people
believed could we have a soul or spirit
to spirit connection happening here to
that that can then be transmitted
further and catalyzed more awakening my
answer is yes that's why happening I
don't know you know it gets transmitted
and then what whatever comes of that is
like on the receivers end yes and when
even this sentence about the greatest
gift being the father's death your
father's death that in itself is
profoundly awakening that is we still
struggle with seeing the greatest
traumas as the greatest treasures
I know very few people who have chosen
to like really awaken to their own
purpose their own higher self whatever
you want to describe that as where
suffering has not been involved agreed
all of the guests have those spirits is
correct yeah you could say the coolest
commonality between them is seeing their
traumas as treasures yeah that's really
the choice and
and is it not possible that you know for
some people that suffering will just
continue as an invitation
until they choose and they still can
choose never to you know to accept that
invitation that's okay too
Wow I've had some very interesting
feelings from my heart throughout this
conversation and especially here at the
end M Hartwell you are Charlie Hartwell
you are you are thank you so much
charlie thank you great thank you
Wow so profound it so enlightening Wow
it's have been an honor thank you thank
you thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
wow let us know how your heart was
gushing throughout that episode please
check out the links in the bio below
into Charlie's work check out the links
in the Bible o to the transformative
technology conference yes vs collector
so can I just say one other thing in
course you may
so as part of my awakening I found a
voice and in my father's death I I found
the voice to become the musician that I
never was so in my father's death I
actually wrote and recorded my first
album I'm on number three now but
there's a there is a there is a song on
that album called soul purpose which is
all about that conversation so if
anybody wants to go to Spotify and place
all purpose by Charlie are well you'll
find it there we'll put the link in the
bio below everyone soul purpose so four
bytes charlie Harwell Wow Wow Wow so
third album now it's out this is you're
on your third and what do you play I
write the music as saying I play the
guitar I play the harmonica
Wow so cool so cool check out all of
Charlie's links in the Bible which are
the links to transform of Technology
conference as well check out those links
thank you to our Co producers really
sprung or Shapiro thank you both very
much thank you thank you check out the
links to our show and the Bible o as
well you can support us on patreon
PayPal cryptocurrencies design cool
merch and get paid support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
organizations in your communities that
you believe in as well and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]